my thing on astrology is I don't think
it's like the stars and stuff but I do
think the proximity of your birthday to
other holidays or lack thereof forms
your personality yeah Leo's always were
like it's a summer you didn't get to
have a birthday party with people and
you had to like figure out a way to get
attention yeah and you're like sunshine
you like entertain yourself yes yeah I'm
like it's I would love to be cool enough
to be like I don't believe in astrology
but I do yeah September was back to
school so my birthday September 4th that
was weird first day of school so I got
like for my birthday I got like a
protractor and like pencils and a
protractor you know what I'm saying I
use it for sex so so like it was all
about just like acade like you know what
I mean my f my birthday was the first
day of school on like a Tuesday MH there
was no like celebrating yeah whereas you
were just like at
like August I was like AUST the part's
here August 12th there is something
thing about like like it's so cute when
humans try to connect because I think we
spend so much time being like oh you
were for this team you're dead to me oh
you voted for this person you're trash
like tell this is what humans do with
their birthdays though like what's your
birthday you're just like talking to a
stranger what's your birthday August
12th August
29th a day we both were born on a day
like not even that close I'll make
anything make sense why did we like what
like not even did that over text I was
like I am a Virgo Moon so I understand
you I understand you yeah I just I'm
trying to reconcile how different we are
and how much I like you oh my god do you
know what I'm saying you're going to
make me cry I love meeting someone that
we're almost different in every one of
our preferences but I like you
more do you know what I mean well cuz
we're both bored with ourselves so when
you find someone wait I'm what I'm bored
with myself so it's don't Pro I am
fascinated I am on the edge of my seat
every day with what I'm going to do next
you're like I have Whiplash just up
riveted by myself but it's fun to talk
to someone with a different perspective
and not be like that's correct well no I
think so many people or makes for a good
podcast yeah they yeah no good you're
this is this is Money in the Bank that's
why I like you not like as a friend I
just mean like this is going to do
numers you're like babe this is
Analytics mean yeah sorry the
advertisers are going to love it we're
never going to speak again okay lose my
number we have good chemistry is what
I'm trying to say I like staring at you
this is my necklace I like that we can
be silent together already wait should
we just see how long what we could be
silent I don't want to here's the thing
I would normally win that but you played
Sports seriously so I feel like you're
super competitive I am really
competitive me too but I've been very um
it's caused a lot of pain competition in
terms of like losing and being like if
you lose you suck you're horrible and
that's why with standup I've tried to be
like this is a creative Avenue and
Comics was like the first time I really
was like oh these are my freaks these
are my people let's be honest women
women in comedy are are underdogs in the
beginning I definitely had the
complaints of I would perform and all
these girls would start to show up and
some of the guys didn't love that like
the room would be like half girls like
it wasn't like all girls oh I'm sure the
M Comics were
pissed and all the hot young girls you
drew this crowd just like is doesn't
like the crowd H is crowd and I they
like don't want to have sex with me this
is how much I want to be friends with
you last night I knew you know when you
like call someone when you know they're
not available cuz you're like I want to
start connecting but I don't have time
right now do you know what I mean like
I'm going to get on a plane at 2:30 at
3:00 you're like ah missed like you know
but it's a thought we're I'm just
putting in the muscle memory of like and
so I saw on I think it was your
Instagram that you WR the improver
something and I didn't not I was going
to be at the comedy store for another
like 20 minutes for two minutes and I
was like okay you had called an Uber
when you texted me yeah no I was in my
car and I was like oh I'm at The Comedy
Store if you're out like this was the
most this was like a friend he literally
said you up like totally at like 10:45
you know it's
I'm in Hollywood in my head I was like
how cool would it be for me to roll up
to The Comedy Store ignore everyone then
just walk up to Whitney dab her up and
just be like what's up and then just
like hang and like talk some comedy
gossip and then be like got to go like
but that we're not going to do that no
it would we were Tire I was so tired
yeah and I was like I want to be on my
Prime Let Me Clear I didn't invite you
to hang out we were never let me just
you okay by the way you didn't reject me
no yes no I think most people now like
surround themselves with people that
they agree with like politically
everything and like I love disagreeing
with somebody and it's not even
disagreeing it's just like I love people
that are different more fascinating and
then I like I'm open to being like Oh I
never thought about that way like cuz I
think a lot of what you do as a comic is
you just take a hot take in a different
opinion just to create an interesting
conversation so I found myself saying
stuff that I don't even believe half the
time because I'm like we just agree on
everything I talk about sism I don't
even know what it means and I brought it
up like it was real totally like I'm
just trying to make something out of
nothing you know if you just agree with
somebody too much and it's just I love
that we naturally don't agree on
anything I love having strong opinions
on things that I don't know about and we
keep picking opposite sides you want to
be my friend I would literally cry I
would love to